What you need to know before having a child in Japan You
won't believe it, but
when a monster attacks the city, it's impossible to seal it away
from your child.Also, you
can never let your child fight with their friends.  I'm not going to open my eyes to wheel cancer.
Make a stock of green tea before you have a child. Once you have a child who will definitely need it, you'll
have a child who will need to abandon the aesthetic sense of goodness,
and you won't have time for Armored Core 6.  When you
have a child in Japan, you get 10,000 yen a month,
which is deducted from the income tax that keeps
going up.The child's medical expenses
are free until he or she enters elementary school, and that keeps going up.The
school deducts it from the consumption tax.  Basically, it
's free.Akira can be shown to 3-year-olds, except for the classes that are required to get into the school.It seems like it's
not a movie.When a girl is born,
never show them the latest season
of PreCure.Goods from the latest season are doubled.  It's
expensive, so instead of looking for a place to stream it, I
bought a Blu-ray set directed by Miyazaki.Trust me, it's
not a sticker, it's a sticker.Even
if you buy a Nagashi Somen utensil, you'll only use it once.
Japan is the best country to raise junior high and high school students who will be able to read only hiragana once again.If you
ignore the dark part-time job, tatami is cooler than wooden flooring.If you
keep having children until someone pees, for better or for worse,
you...  I heard that you're going on your long-awaited trip to Yakushima to fall in love with Pokemon again.You
can get the materials from the city hall.It's from the
pediatrician's office where you usually go.It's from the
public health center.It's from the hospital where your child was born.I guess this is the place to go.Please
wait a moment
this year.  Even if you're a Sony fan, you'll
eventually end up buying a Nintendo game console. In Japan, backpacks cost 100,000 yen. There's
nothing more frustrating than having your child say you're good at Japanese.